the Joe Rogan experience Cheers cheers
man come on man salud
yeah we just tested on um yes
negative it's apparently it's been some
controversy about this so just let me
write let everybody know right away
there's no shortage of antibody tests
what we're using there's no shortage of
them people saying why do people on the
frontlines a lot of people it's just
misunderstanding and confusion these
tests there's no shortage of I
understand some people in some places
have a hard time getting access to the
test that's not the case here so I've
taken upon myself to test everybody as
they come into the studio this is not
taking away from anybody that's on the
front lines it's not taking tests away
from any medical workers the test that
they would use for them particularly the
act they're using swabs
I mean look man those [ __ ] people
that are working in those hospitals and
the medical workers those people are
legit heroes yes you know and if I found
out that there was something we were
doing that was somehow another taking
away from their ability to be tested I
would never do it you know so people got
upset apparently because well also
people writing articles about things
because there's you know it's like it's
a hot topic right in their home - yeah I
get it you know but when I posted that
Donnell and I were Rona free people like
someone someone posted some story
whether it was hilarious
I'd go out of my way to not read
comments and these [ __ ] are
writing stories where they're taking
comments from Instagram and using them
as quotes just some random Magoo that's
posting something this one of them said
we were a low-key flexing that we had
tests that's just someone just looking
to use the term loading and they don't
have any place for its Loki flexing he's
got a corona test so it's a it's a test
that tests you for antibodies and you 11
at my face the entire time I shared with
you earlier today there was a new study
that Jamie TV
that study it is out of I think it's
outta UCLA is that what it's out of its
it says early antibody tests indicate
far more cases and a much lower
mortality rate right so they think
there's at least 400,000 people have
been infected in in California so the
mortality rate is way way lower than
they previously thought it was at least
in California you know it obviously
varies there's a crazy disease it's
crazy it doesn't make any sense it
varies depending upon what your physical
condition whether or not you've been
smoking whether or not there's
apparently a great benefit to exercising
regularly even while you have it if you
catch it
exercising mmm but then there was this
[ __ ] crazy thing what does that guys
name the fox thing put up will do the
first I find it's LA Times it's got the
subscription blocker on it oh these sons
of [ __ ] here I'll send you another
one there's a there's one on la comm I
belong the LA Times I can give you my
look at you I support you I do like
movies there did I get it I just I don't
have the time for that here it goes
early antibody test indicates far more
kovat 19 cases lower mortality rate
there's a decrease in the number of
deaths the study indicates that there
could be hundreds of thousands of people
could be infected without knowing it
that's what's so weird about it let me
ask you this question though can you
explain mortality rate this is like yes
the amount of people that get it how
many of them died so if it's a high
mortality rate isn't yeah right like
Ebola right vicious mortality rate yes
really but rabies the worst 100% yes
rabies is like 99.99% the only time they
if they catch it before the the symptom
set in you survive survive but if they
don't catch it before the symptoms like
if you just get rabies you don't get
over every black person I know always
crosses the street when you see a random
dog
[Laughter]
[Applause]